I would like to know is an answer to a
very simple question are we alone as
conscious beings in this entire buzzing
400 billion star galaxy one of 10 to the
10th other galaxies
it seems pretty implausible the modern
search for extraterrestrial intelligence
or SETI began in 1959 when two cornell
physicists Giuseppi cocconi
and Philip Morrison published an article
in Nature that outlined the possibility
of using radio and microwaves to
communicate between the stars in order
for this to work researchers assume that
any intelligent civilization will have
discovered the ability to transmit radio
waves this assumption is based in part
on the fact that it took human beings
only 80 years to figure out how to do
this following Alessandro Voltas
discovery of batteries and electric
current the premise is quite simple we
can create radio waves by sending short
pulses of electric current through wires
these waves can then travel beyond our
atmosphere and out through space with
little interference
once these radio or electromagnetic
waves are sent out they can be received
using antennas and turned back into
electrical pulses in 1960 Frank Drake
conducted the first search for radio
signals from other solar systems much
like turning a radio dial Drake was
trying to scan the sky in order to tune
in to faint radio signals that might be
coming from other worlds though this
first attempt did not result in any
noteworthy findings researchers have
been scanning the Stars ever since so
there is some chance that in the next
few decades we will get the signal from
some spectacularly distant spectacularly
exotic civilization and everything on
earth will as a consequence change that
is possible the interesting thing about
the SETI search is that although we
claim that we're looking for
extraterrestrial intelligence we can't
actually define what an intelligent
signal is and so a starting point is to
say we look for a signal which nature
will not produce by any mechanism that
we understand an important question
emergence how can we ever know if such a
signal is coming from an intelligent
source at the first SETI meeting in 1961
John Lilly proposed that researchers
study dolphin languages to help them
learn more about what extraterrestrial
signals might be like much of this early
work culminated in the research
conducted by Lawrence R Doyle and Brenda
McGowan Doyle and McCowan x' work is
based on the assumption that if there is
some common trait in both human and
non-human communication systems then
extraterrestrial communication systems
should also share this trait they
analyzed a long sequence of
vocalizations from both adult and baby
humans and dolphins and in the case of
dolphins this was a set of whistles and
clicks now human babies learn to speak
through a process of vocal imitation
slowly amassing a larger and larger set
of sound signals however during what is
known as the babbling phase the sounds
produced are more or less random or
unstructured to see this Doyle and
McCowan plotted the different sound
signals against their frequency or how
often they occur and then they ordered
the symbols in the graph according to
frequency with the most common symbols
on the left and the least common on the
right with human babies the slope is
nearly level as all sound signals
produced occur fairly evenly or randomly
however as children learn the language
of their parents they narrow their sound
repertoire to fit the model to which
they are exposed and as a result
structure is imposed on our speech
patterns
consequently the slope of this graph
converges towards a 45-degree angle or
negative one slope on a log-log chart
this is known as zip slaw what's
interesting is that this same slope
appears in different human languages and
seems to be a pattern all humans share
and even more surprising is that this
pattern also emerged when Doyle and
McCowan analyzed non-human communication
they found that the whistle sounds
produced by baby dolphins seem to be
distributed in a pattern similar to
human babies during the babbling phase
at first the dolphin whistles are more
or less unstructured and by the time
they reach adulthood the graph converges
on a slope of about negative one which
is the same as humans but this sort of
analysis looks only at individual
signals or words and doesn't say
anything about the deeper linguistic
structure of either human or dolphin
communication systems and let's clarify
what we mean by deeper structure with an
example if I select a random word from a
book and asked you to guess what it is
you will have no clue what it might be
and will have to simply guess if instead
I give you a random word from a book and
ask you to predict the word that follows
it you will still have to guess however
you'll notice it's likely easier to
guess this word and if I give you a
sequence of two words from a book and
ask you to predict the third word it
becomes more predictable still and if
you are given a sequence of three words
this trend continues the ability to
guess is even easier it seems that as a
result of the structure of language the
freedom of choice decreases as we look
at longer and longer strings of words
intuitively this is why we can finish
each other's sentences now to quantify
this Doyle and McCowan Bohr rode Claude
Shannon's measure of entropy which as
you recall is a measure of surprise
entropy can be thought of as the number
of yes-or-no quest
or bits required to guess the next word
so as predictability increases the
information entropy decreases and Doyle
and McCowan calculated the entropy for
different depths or orders so single
words his first order groups of two
words a second order groups of three
words is third order and so on and then
they plotted the value of information
entropy against this depth and for adult
humans as we may expect they found that
the information entropy decreases as the
depth increases and this is a result of
the rule structure in our communication
systems amazingly Doyle and McCowan did
the same thing with dolphin languages
and found the same pattern dolphin
communication systems display decreasing
information entropy as we look at longer
sequences of sound signals this means
that in dolphin communication systems
there is a rule structure which emerges
and arguably this also allows dolphins
to finish each other sentences too now
contrast this to just a random sequence
of symbols which has a flat line on this
information entropy graph since there is
no conditional dependence between
symbols now because this pattern emerges
in both human and non-human
communication systems Doyle and McCowan
have suggested that this decreasing of
entropy is essential for the
transmission of what we might call
knowledge as Doyle puts it if we get a
narrowband signal a negative one slope
on the Zipp plot and higher-order
Shannon entropy s we've nailed it and
all of this rests on a simple premise
that aliens two can finish each other's
sentences how can I help you to
communicate all this how I am able
assembly form of volition
I have been able to incorporate certain
of dr. Wyman's functional processes as
dr. Wyman's death necessary who is I can
communicate and without even
understanding the language or culture of
the other human or non-human species
Claude Shannon's entropy is a unit of
measure that can allow us to detect the
presence of these structural rules
regardless of meaning Claude Shannon's
model of information was born out of a
desire to save time over the telegraph
wires and this led to the global unit of
information the bit a single difference
now the backbone of our information
economy the increasingly digital and
network technologies that drive our
modern world point to the power and
persistence of Claude Shannon's ideas
the bit is here to stay and the study of
information theory will continue to play
a key role in our technological and
social innovations on earth and perhaps
beyond I think even if there's a
plausible argument for a few we've got
to keep looking I even go further than
that if there's a plausible argument
that there isn't anybody out there
bearing in mind that we can be wrong we
ought to keep looking because the
question is of the most supreme
importance it calibrates our place in
the universe it tells us who we are and
so it is worthwhile trying to find other
civilizations I would say